- I look at losing as a positive
mainly because everybody
here doesn't like losing
'cause they're worried
what other people
think about their loss.
- [Man] They're programmed.
- I don't give a fuck
what other people
think about my "L".
It's my "L".
You go worry about yourself.
This is my "L".
I'm not worried what my
wife thinks about my "L".
Not worried about what
my kids think about my "L".
I don't give a fuck about what
my parents think about my "L".
you think about my "L".
It's my "L".
And the reason people don't like
losses is not so much
they don't like losses,
they're worried about
what everybody else
thinks about their loss.
That's the fucking gear.
(light music)